Alright guys, so before you guys move on to the course videos, I want to give you guys
some tips on how to start, okay?
So I want you to watch each and every single video in this course first.
Once you do that, I then want you to watch all the videos on my YouTube channel, because
on my YouTube channel, I show different variations of each strategy, not each strategy, but one
of my favorite strategies, okay?
So what I want you to do is to watch all of the videos, don't skip any video, because
I share a lot of details and you might miss if you skip any one of the videos, okay?
So watch all the course videos and after that, watch all the videos on my YouTube channel,
okay?
You have to watch all of them.
So that, and then you're going to understand each and everything correctly, okay?
And to join the Discord server, after you finish the course, there is a link at the
very bottom of the endgame section of the course.
I recommend that you watch all the videos and then join the Discord server, okay?
So anyways, I hope you guys enjoy this course and I'll see you guys in the next one.